yvan glock s'est effritée avec tes
petites soeurs très drôle
oui la grille cheat était bien trop beau
gosse pour ce business pourquoi tu
l'arnaqué n'hésitez pas à re mac est là
juste une négociation en cours c'est
tout après négociations en cours du tout
moi tu es vraiment pareil vent l'argent
ils apprennent comment tu as su que
j'avais ressortir de là vivant était sûr
de ton coup on est dans le commerce du
jour on n'est pas chez les bisounours on
est au costa rica et des fois tu t'en
mangelinck y est mais là tu savais que
j'allais me faire défoncer c'est tout
jobs
je comprends tu vas avoir bonne
conscience bosse dans l'humanitaire mais
si tu veux tu acheté ta [ __ ] deal et
que ton boss te confie la mission
d'aller de faire démonter
tu y vas tu prends pas rater et du
rapliq hélico en disant est ce que vous
voulez xalima prendre encore une
parce qu'aujourd'hui tu vois ton boss a
offert les clés du royaume